what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and we just got our very
first teaser trailer for Thor love and
thunder and it did not disappoint it was
awesome we got our first look at
ravenger Thor with the Guardians of the
Galaxy and her first look at the Mighty
Thor Jane Foster now there's a lot
happening in this trailer they introduce
other gods like Zeus and Gore the god
butcher is not in this trailer which is
interesting because there's a rumor
going around that perhaps Gore the god
butcher could actually make his first
appearance in Moon Knight we know Moon
Knight has introduced gods and we know
that Gore the god butcher well he's the
god butcher he goes around killing God
so could they perhaps be saving that
first look for Moon Knight we're gonna
talk about everything and break down
this trailer so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos let's dive into it so right off
the bat like I mentioned there are some
rumors that have been going around that
states maybe Gore the god butcher could
be appearing in one of the episodes of
Moon Knight now I have seen episodes one
through four and I have not seen Gore
the god butcher yet but he could appear
in episodes 5 or 6. after all he is
called Gore the god butcher for a reason
he goes around and he starts killing
Gods now if you're not familiar with who
Gore the god butcher is he is going to
be the main villain of Thor love and
thunder and he is going to be played by
Christian Bale now here's a brief
backstory on why Gore the god butcher
wants to kill all of the Gods Gore was
born on a planet with no names where he
was taught to worship the gods however
his life was filled with tragedy he had
a wife and a bunch of kids but sadly his
wife died and all of his children died
as well and right before his last son
died he prayed and begged the gods to
give him help but his son ended up dying
and he started to express that he didn't
believe that the gods were real and this
led to him being exiled by his people
however while wandering in the desert
waiting to die himself he witnessed two
Gods fighting one of the Gods was the
dark elder god null the Symbiote God and
the other was a gold armored purple skin
in God the gods fell to the floor and
Gore went up to them shocked to believe
that the gods actually existed the gold
armored God begged him for help however
as he was begging him the dark Elder
God's sword turned into an amorphous
mass and it bonded to him and he created
the all-black necro sword and he used
this to kill the God and from here on
out he was just furious that the gods
actually did exist but they didn't come
to his Aid so from here on out he set
out to kill Gods now when this trailer
it actually looks like we see a lot of
gods as we see Olympus in this trailer
and Zeus and I'm assuming this is where
Gore the god butcher is planning to
strike and it looks like they're all
going to be in a lot of trouble but
we'll get into that in a bit now 411
Thunder of course takes place after the
events of Avengers endgame where Thor
left with the Guardians of the Galaxy
leaving new Asgard to Valkyrie who we
see in this trailer is now the king of
Asgard but the trailer starts off with
Thor kind of running through different
phases in life it shows him as a little
kid it then shows him as a young adult
in which we actually see the classic
Thor Comic costume right here he then
ages up a couple of more times until we
get to where he is right now where he
says that his hands were once used for
battle now they're but humble tools used
for peace we see him plant Stormbreaker
into the ground which is interesting
because we know that the handle for
Stormbreaker was made from groot's arm
so the fact that he's planting it into
the ground kind of like a tree implies
that the handle might actually kind of
be alive still either that or Thor is
just kind of getting a little bit more
grounded now we see him meditating on a
distant planet contemplating who exactly
he is and who he wants to be in life as
we hear him say I need to figure out
exactly who I am now we cut to the
Marvel Studios logo and then we see Thor
getting in shape because when we left
him in Avengers end game he was still
very much bro Thor and if you take a
look at the hat that he's wearing you
can see the classic Avengers logo and
over the top of it he wrote strongest to
where the Hat reads the strongest
Avenger this is a call back to Thor
Ragnarok where him and the Hulk fought
over who the strongest Avenger was where
Thor of course claimed that he was the
strongest Avenger but Hulk said that he
was also noticed the Skeleton on the
right which seems to be from a really
really big being that Thor might have
defeated in the past which could be how
Thor knew that he would be there and the
chains would be there as well now in the
next scene we see Thor show off his new
slash old body because it's how he's
always looked as he takes off a coat
revealing a new look now we know that
this look is going to be called ravenger
Thor the ravenger is of course being the
group that Peter Quill was a part of in
which they would all wear red leather
jackets and as we can see here Thor is
wearing a red leather jacket but he
ripped the sleeves off and this is a
look taken directly from the comic Thor
thunder strike he's even wearing the
same boots now we see him with the
Guardians of the Galaxy because of
course he left with them and some blue
creatures in the back now these could be
the intadites from the comics and it
does look like the Guardians are
actually helping protect them if you
notice in the scene where Thor takes off
his jacket and stands on top of the rock
below him we can actually see quill
hiding behind the rock we can see nebula
in the background and behind her we can
actually see one of these people is dead
now the next scene shows the Guardians
of the Galaxy running towards a battle
and Thor turns away now in the next
scene since he says his superhero days
are over I'm assuming this right here is
Thor not wanting to really battle
anymore so he chooses to not join this
fight at least as the same Thor that he
has always been because this is clearly
the same scene where he rips off the
coat and reveals ravenger Thor so I'm
expecting him to walk away change into a
ravanger and then join the battle
because when he says goodbye to the
Guardians of the Galaxy in the next
scene we can see that he's still wearing
the ravenger clothes the Guardians take
off and go through a hex point which
we've seen them do in the Guardians
films that allows them to go to
essentially any place in the Galaxy they
want to and we also see the awesome Korg
he's back protecting Thor from all the
ghosts
pissed off ghost
and as you can see he is dressed as a
ravager as well but Thor and Korg leave
the Guardians now the next scene shows
new Asgard and the first thing that we
notice is a boat being pulled over the
water not in the water over the Water by
Two Goats these goats are Thor's
mystical goats tooth gnasher and tooth
grinder in the comics they pull Thor's
Chariot and they can take him through
different parts of the Galaxy and even
into different dimensions now in this
scene it kind of looks like they're
pulling a party boat as the boat goes by
you can see a sign that says cocktail on
it which implies that this is pretty
much a party boat but on the boat you
can catch a quick peek of Valkyrie and
Korg now the next scene is of Olympus
but we'll come back to that in just a
bit because the scenes after this we
actually see Thor in new Asgard he seems
to be having a pretty good time as we
see him kiss a girl we then see him on a
boat floating through space now tooth
gnasher and tooth grinder probably
pulled him into space but in the next
scene we see him using Stormbreaker to
open the bifrost portal which we know he
can do as they explained that he could
in Avengers Infinity War here we also
get a new look at Thor's brand new suit
we can see that it is very much gold and
blue now kind of closer to a comic
accurate version now in the next scene
we see Olympus and going back to the
scene that we saw before that is also
Olympus now of course many people know
Olympus from Greek mythology but in the
MCU Olympus is its own realm that exists
outside of Earth it's pretty much almost
exactly like Asgard except it is home to
different gods and here we actually see
Zeus and we actually see him catch a
lightning bolt which is pretty dang cool
now although we only see the back of
them we do know that Zeus is going to be
played by Russell Crowe the next thing
we have is Thor and Korg looking at a
giant Beast covered in snow of course
it's dead and this is taken directly
from the comics the comic Thor God of
Thunder now from here we get another
look at new Asgard and we can see that
it's pretty much at this point a tourist
attraction and that makes sense if Thor
appeared in real life on our planet a
lot of people would probably want to go
and see a real life God if you look in
the the background especially on the
right you can see some golden buildings
which is very similar to the old Asgard
where they used to live but you can also
see a bunch of cruise ships in the
background as well showing us that
Asgard really is a tourist location
which kind of makes sense because
they're gonna have to make money some
way they didn't really have to worry
about money on the old Asgard but on
Earth it looks like they do now then
they show Valkyrie who again is the king
of Asgard right now in an Earthly
meeting that you can tell she just
clearly does not enjoy if you take a
look at the sign on the right we can see
that it actually says renewable energy
conference and this is probably pretty
funny slash boring for valkyrie as she
comes from Asgard a magical realm where
energy probably isn't a problem but you
can tell that she really doesn't like
dealing with the politics of Earth now
from here we get another scene of
Olympus and we can see a giant statue of
Zeus in the background holding a
lightning bolt and if you take a close
look at the bottom we can actually see
Jane Foster's The Mighty Thor walking
side by side next to Thor notice the two
long red capes this is Thor and to his
right is Jane Foster's The Mighty Thor
we also see Valkyrie and Korg there as
well now as these scenes play we hear
Peter Quill's voice talking to Thor most
likely giving him advice before the
Guardians take off and leave Thor and
Korg and he says if you ever feel lost
just look into the eyes of the people
that you love as he says this quill is
looking past Thor to his team the
Guardians of the Galaxy he's also kind
of sad because as we know Gamora is no
longer there there is a version of
Gamora that is out there however it is
not the one that he fell in love with we
do know that this story is definitely
going to be explored in Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. here we also get a little
bit of a taste of what the comedy is
going to be like in Thor love and
thunder if it's anything like Thor
Ragnarok it's going to be hilarious and
the scene shows us that quill says look
into the eyes of the people you love and
he looks past Thor but Thor is looking
directly into his eyes and kind of
interrupts his gaze we see Star-Lord
slowly start moving his head trying to
look past Thor but Thor keeps moving his
head to get in the way trying to look
into Peter Quill's eyes implying that
he's come to love him but of course in a
good comedic moment Peter Quill says not
me and Thor says oh I was just trying to
listen and speaking of love the very
last scene that we get is our very first
look at Jane Foster's The Mighty Thor
wielding a mended mjolnir now this is
going to be coming from The Mighty Thor
Comic line where Jane Foster does become
the Mighty Thor now in this comic line
she also has cancer and every time she
transforms into the Mighty Thor the
cancer gets worse and taika watiti has
confirmed that this is a storyline that
they will be exploring in this movie but
one thing that is for sure and is really
awesome is that the Mighty Thor Jane
Foster is worthy to lift mjolnir and
Natalie Portman looks like she gained
some weight to play this role she's
looking pretty buff there and I'm really
digging her as the Mighty Thor and that
is our first teaser trailer we did not
get a look at Gore but we did get a look
at the Mighty Thor Jane Foster we did
get a look at Zeus kinda from behind but
a great look at Olympus and of course a
lot of great shots of Thor ravanger Thor
and the Guardians of the Galaxy let me
know what you think about this trailer
in the comments it's down below and if
you spotted any really cool Easter eggs
be sure to put those in the comments as
well don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest Marvel videos for live
updates you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof